nous allons maintenant parler de
sexologie et des sexualités
c'est un sujet tabou vous souvenez
certainement du rapport kinsey c'était
aux états unis en 1953 et puis en 1960
très exactement ce fut le rapport
masters il a fallu attendre 1972 pour
qu'en france on parle sans tabou de ce
sujet tabou justement avec le rapport
simon est bien aujourd'hui une nouvelle
enquête un nouveau sondage a été réalisé
sur la sexualité des français
un sondage qui nous est détaillée par
jérôme camille je pense vcv les
personnes à résoudre leurs problèmes
dans le domaine de la sexualité
vous imaginez un jour aller voir un
sexologue
[Musique]
pourquoi pas un signe enfin non plus
hein
j'avais pu voir s'il ya un problème dans
tant c'est plutôt entre et de personnes
qui ont les rapports qui ils doivent
avoir une solution qui va pour une
solution
je crois que je pense d'abord aux gens
qu'il revend plus proche de moi
peut-être qu'à quelqu'un qui peut
confier plutôt qu'un seul salaire s'ils
ne sont pas très bavards pour parler de
leur sexualité
les français en revanche consultent de
plus en plus souvent leur médecin
généraliste pour des problèmes sexuels
frais d'un médecin sur deux constate une
demande plus fréquentes au cours des
dernières années
une demande faite en majorité par les
adultes parmi eux les hommes consultent
deux fois plus que les femmes
les problèmes sexuels sont évoqués en
premier lieu à propos de troubles
organiques impuissance ou frigidité sept
fois sur dix autres motifs tout aussi
fréquente consultation la dépression et
l'anxiété
pour les médecins généralistes ces
questions relèvent tout à fait de leurs
compétences dans 7 cas sur 10 la
thérapeutique proposé prendra la forme
d'une assistance psychologique d'un
dialogue face aux problèmes sexuels le
recours aux spécialistes reste limitée à
des cas très spécifiques et généraliste
adresse rarement leurs patients au
gynécologue au sexologue manque
d'information peut être question de
méfiance plus tôt
[Musique]
j'ai un peu dur du malade ou du médecin
parce que le médecin soit toujours
facile me parler des choses parce que on
a parfois du mal à mettre les mots
exacts on peut dire est ce que tu bandes
de ce que quand on connaît quelqu'un
mais par exemple déjà propriétaire plus
possible par fonder un peu de mal alors
on reste un peu abusif parfois nous
mêmes on dit on en parle à la prochaine
consultation enfin je veux dire c'est le
médecin peut être à l'aise et il peut
aussi être un peu en difficulté sa
défense en rapport avec le malade à ce
moment là comment aider et comme les
difficultés pour je dirais pour faire
une veille de la consultation en matière
de sexualité ou de sexologie qu'est ce
que vous faites vous adresser votre
balade un sexologue
la plupart du temps oui j'adresse au
sexologue met alors à ce moment là on
s'aperçoit que les gens soient ils
tombent sur un sexologues psychologues
ce qui m'est arrivé récemment et il se
trouve dans le psycho thérapie il dit
c'est parce que j'ai demandé les
problèmes de sexualité se soigne comment
je pense que tout se soit nous manque à
l'individu se prend en main et il doit
guérir
s'il a des problèmes sexuels je crois
que tout épanouissement se fait pas nous
laisse penser que tu allais à la portée
de n'importe qui mais avec la libération
homosexuelle sont apparus de nouvelles
maladies que l'on appelle désormais des
maladies sexuellement transmissibles
alors ça c'est autre chose c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave et extrêmement
sérieux mais les gens ne consultent pas
les sexologues pour ces maladies là et
consultent des biologistes ou leur
médecin généraliste
le sexologue est en fait le médecin du
plaisir et le médecin de l'entente
conjugales ce n'est pas le médecin de
l'infection est ce qu'on vient vous
parler librement de ses problèmes
oui parce que vous savez nous sommes au
fond souvent le dernier recours hélas du
reste est peut-être plus librement
qu'aux médecins de famille et puis nous
sommes un peu anonyme et puis nous avons
la réputation de savoir de quoi l'on va
parler nous avons la réputation aussi de
poser les questions qu'ils font au
moment qu'il faut avec les termes qu'il
faut et la grande question n'est pas là
la question principale ce qui ne faut
pas finir trop tard
mais en temps de sexuel difficultés du
couple un seul mot n'a pas été encore
prononcé le mot amour mais